una reflexión que actúa en el plano
cartesiano lleva al punto g en el punto
h el punto g en el punto h y al punto s
en el punto t el punto s en el punto t
cuál es la línea de reflexión y bien
recuerden la línea de reflexión es la
línea que pasa por los puntos medios de
estos dos segmentos del segmento gh y
del segmento st se vería algo así más o
menos
más o menos algo así se vería y entonces
el punto medio de gh que estaría por
aquí y el punto medio de st
estaría por acá más o menos tienen que
estar sobre esta línea cuando hago una
reflexión la idea es que por ejemplo
desde el punto g dejó caer una
perpendicular a la línea de reflexión
dejó caer una perpendicular y luego
continuó sigo de largo por la misma
distancia que recorre y para llegar deje
a la línea de reflexión así que al hacer
eso debería llegar a h lo mismo de s
hacia p primero dejó caer una
perpendicular a la línea de reflexión
y luego continuó por la misma instancia
que acabo de recorrer para llegar a la
imagen de ese pero bueno esto está
dibujado de un modo muy feo el gemelo
gorro y vamos a hacer las cosas con
cuidado
ok
entonces comencemos
cuáles son las coordenadas de que pues
las coordenadas de g son menos
2,6 y cuáles son las coordenadas de h
pues son dos coma menos 2
entonces cuál es la coordenada el punto
medio es el promedio de las coordenadas
menos dos más dos es cero cero entre
20 así que la coordenada x va a ser cero
la cordela va a ser menos 6 más menos 2
que sería menos 8 entre 2 que sería
menos 4 así que el punto medio sería el
punto cero
menos 4
escribo 0 - 4 ese es el punto medio del
segmento gh y ahora que hay de st
ese tiene coordenadas
tiene coordenadas 1.5
con 5.5
y te tiene coordenadas
tiene coordenadas menos 9.5
y
9.5
coma
- 5.5
5.5 así que cuáles son las coordenadas
del punto medio veamos tengo
1.5
+
9.5
entre dos para la coordenada x y
5.5
más o menos 5.5 para a entre 2 para la
coordenada y y cuánto es esto pues esto
es 1.5 más menos 9.5 es 1.5 menos 9.5
que es menos 8 entre 2 sería menos 4
-
45.5 más menos 5.5 es 0 así que el punto
medio sería el punto menos 40 y la línea
de reflexión sería la línea que pasa por
estos dos puntos que más o menos se
vería algo así
algo así
ahora podemos escribir sobre su ecuación
en la forma clásica de punto pendiente
que es igual a mx más b
primero vamos a averiguar la pendiente
en vamos a averiguar esa pendiente pues
cuál es mi cambio en mi cambio y es esta
diferencia pasó de estar en cero a menos
cuatro así que me cambien y
cambien es d
menos cuatro menos cuatro unidades y me
cambio mx cuanto vale mi cambio en x
vale
pues pasa a estar en menos 4 a 0 así que
me cambio en x es de 4
4 positivo por lo tanto mi pendiente m
va a ser igual a mi cambio
entre mi cambio en x
y esto cuánto es pues por cada cuatro
unidades que avanzó en dirección x de
siendo cuatro unidades por lo tanto está
pendiente va a ser igual a menos 4 entre
4 que es menos 1
para encontrar cuánto vale la
intersección con el eje y de la orden al
origen pues simplemente tengo que
evaluar la función en cero pero yo sé
que el punto cero como menos 4 está en
la línea por lo tanto está b tiene que
ser menos 4 de modo que la ecuación de
la recta sería y es igual a menos x
menos 4
perfecto ahora me preguntan cuáles son
las coordenadas cuáles son las
coordenadas de la imagen del punto menos
dos menos dos pues menos dos menos dos
está en la recta si ya sustituyó x igual
a menos 2 obtengo menos menos dos menos
cuatro que sería 2 menos 4 que sería
menos 2 por lo tanto este punto está en
la recta de reflexión y que le pasa un
punto en la recta de reflexión cuando lo
reflejo se queda exactamente en dónde
está por lo tanto las coordenadas de la
imagen son menos dos coma menos dos y ya
acabamos